elon musk is by far the billionaire with
the most favorable public perception
from his memes to his trolls over the
years
elon musk has built up a reputation for
being relatable
empathetic and most importantly human
but within the last month elon's persona
crumbled over a single tweet
don't get me wrong here eighty to ninety
percent of fanboys don't feel any
different towards eon
however a solid ten to twenty percent
have completely flipped on their one
savior
citing that they feel betrayed so here's
how a simple tweet tarnished a
reputation and built over
decades taking a look back
elon's fiasco with bitcoin started about
a year ago in the summer of 2020.
before that he did share his thoughts on
podcasts here and there
but this is when he actually got
involved with the crypto community
in july of 2020 yellow must tweeted a
meme showing dogecoin
overtaking the global financial system
while this was just a meme
this was the first indication that elon
musk was paying attention to the crypto
space
and that he saw its potential to
overtake the traditional financial
system
his next tweet about crypto came in
december of 2020
where he posted a meme that illustrated
that the temptation of bitcoin was
irresistible he quickly followed up with
the reply to ben mesrick
agreeing that he'd never turned down
getting paid in bitcoin again
this reply is especially ironic
considering what would eventually
transpire
anyway all of this hype would eventually
peak on february 9th of 2021
when tesla announced that they not only
bought 1.5 billion
worth of bitcoin but also that they
would accept bitcoin
as a payment very soon this was actually
an extremely controversial decision
on the internet all we saw was fanboys
praising elon musk and tesla for
supporting bitcoin
but behind the scenes wall street was
not pleased by
any means traditional wall street
investors like gary black who is a
former goldman sachs executive
sold all of their tesla stock right
after the announcement from tesla
over the next month tesla stock would
sell off from the mid-800s
down to the mid 500s and tesla has been
unable to really break past 700
ever since despite the sell-off it
seemed like elon musk was leaning even
more
into the crypto community on march 24th
elon tweeted that tesla would not
convert the bitcoin they received into
fiat currency
this was a very bold move here's the
thing
by this point many companies had started
to accept bitcoin and various cryptos
as payment but the move was generally a
pr move
intended to draw attention to the
company as opposed to a genuine belief
in the technology
most of these companies would convert
the crypto to fiat currency as soon as
they received it
tesla's choice to not convert their
bitcoin really showcased her belief in
crypto
long term with that being said though
we're not sure how many people
even bought tesla's using bitcoin so the
choice to keep the bitcoin they receive
as bitcoin was likely not that big of a
decision financially
in terms of principle though this was
massive
throughout april and early may musk's
involvement in the crypto
space would peak elon would tweet about
dogecoin left and right
and he would even mention dogecoin
several times on saturday night live
considering all of this positive energy
elon's tweet on may 12th was a stab from
the back for many
on may 12 2021 elon would announce that
tesla would no longer accept bitcoin
as payment citing bitcoin's high energy
consumption
elon did confirm that tesla will not
sell any of their bitcoin
but that doesn't mean that tesla didn't
already reduce their bitcoin holdings
when elon made this tweet bitcoin had
already stagnated for a couple of months
in the 50 to 60k range
momentum was slowing down and elon's
tweet caused bitcoin to drop to the low
50k range
this u-turn itself put off many of
elon's fans but
elon's subsequent effect on the bitcoin
price would really seal the deal
on may 16 2021 elon agreed with a tweet
that suggested that it would not be
surprising to see tesla
sell their entire bitcoin position this
was the final straw
the fear that tesla may have sold all of
their bitcoin and the other institutions
may follow
caused bitcoin investors to pay excel
within hours
bitcoin crashed from 50k to the low 40k
range
china would build off of this fear and
pump out some fearful news right after
and this would cause bitcoin to crash to
just under 30k
since then bitcoin has pingpong between
30 and 40k
meaning that people who invest in the 50
to 60k range lost upwards of 50
of their entire investment and virtually
all of these individuals
blamed elon now in reality bitcoin had
stagnated for months
and he was just looking for a reason to
correct unfortunately for elon
he became the catalyst that pushed
bitcoin over the edge
at this point it likely would have been
a great idea to stay quiet
and let things cool down but elon would
continue to tweet
on june 3rd 2021 he would tweet bitcoin
and a heartbreak emoji
by now fans were fed up with elon's
tweets about bitcoin
and many would lash back here's some of
the top replies
you've already lost all respect just go
away
no i was just about 10 from breaking
even
and now the crypto market has crashed
again why do you do this to us
elon i put my trust in you tesla
heartbreak at first glance it seems like
a bunch of elon fanboys are butthurt
because they bought bitcoin at the top
and lost money hand over fist
but i don't actually think losing money
is the primary reason fans lashed out
at elon i mean these guys lose money
diamond handing
all the time i think the primary reason
fans were put off
is because elon was no longer perceived
as one of us
until then it seemed like elon was on
the side of the retailers
he trashed on short selling hedge funds
he supported decentralized finance
and he led retailers to believe that he
would huddle bitcoin
if elon simply outlined some drawbacks
to bitcoin and the bitcoin crashed
i don't think people would have been
that mad as long as elon was still
holding the line
or in other words as long as elon was
still invested
the main factor that pushed people over
the edge is the idea that elon pumped a
bitcoin on the backs of retail investors
and then dumped it at the very top now
we don't actually know if elon did sell
tesla's bitcoin
at the top but at this point it no
longer matters
whether tesla sold a bitcoin or not elon
has already been singled out as not
being one of us
and this root belief has left fanboys to
question everything about elon musk
starting with his tweeting for a long
time fanboys believed that elon was
simply another guy just like them
tweeting about his thoughts but now many
are starting to question avion's
tweeting has more to do
with the desire for attention did elon
ever actually believe in crypto and
gamestop
or did he just want to be on the good
side of retail investors
personally i think it was always a
combination of both
one of the main reasons elon even
started a twitter was to promote his
companies
which didn't have that much money to
market themselves to successfully
promote your companies
you obviously have to draw attention to
yourself while also being on the good
side of retail investors
as spacex and tesla have grown to a much
better financial position however
elon has become more relaxed with his
tweeting simply tweeting his thoughts
about hot topics
at first retailers completely ignored
the marketing aspect of elon's twitter
but now that elon's an evil billionaire
that's all they talk about
aside from questioning his tweets
fanboys have started to question his
intentions
altogether is elon truly attempting to
push forward humanity
or does he just have a savior complex i
mean
elon has made it clear in the past that
he's not trying to be anyone's savior
he's just trying to work on something
that makes him excited about the future
um but i want to be clear i like i'm not
trying to be anyone's savior
that is not the i'm just
trying to think about the future and not
be sad
it's really as simple as that and it's
always been as simple as that
but fanboys had hyped up elon to be some
fearless humanity warrior for years
and now that perception is crumbling now
that elon's intentions are in question
all of his past actions are in question
as well
why was elon working tesla employees 100
hours per week
did elon actually have a hard childhood
like he claims
why have so many tesla executives quit
did elon screw over the founders of
tesla
so many questions have come up which
have brought elon's integrity and
morality
into question but all these questions
are completely irrelevant
because they're nothing new and that
brings me on to my final
and most important reason fans are
starting to turn on musk
which is that super fans have ignored
when convenient
for years yes elon is an extremely
strict boss that works employees
extremely hard spacex and tesla were
startups within industries that are
nearly impossible to break into
so there's really no alternative to
working to the bone
and yes elon did not found tesla and he
eventually had major issues with the
founders
and yes the founders did in fact sue him
but this information has been public
for years i mean the lawsuit was
literally filed in 2009
however superfans chose to ignore it
when they were making 200 percent on
tesla stock in a single month
and what about allah's manipulations
upwards
people clearly got pissed off when an
elon tweet crashed bitcoin
but what about when an elon tweet shot
up gamestop over 100
overnight and what about the time that
elon pumped dogecoin from a nameless
meme coin that was not even worth a
penny
to 40 cents today it looks like none of
them cared when he manipulated the
market
upwards so why is it any different when
the same thing happens
downwards clearly people have just been
ignoring his actions
when they benefit them at the end of the
day elon musk has
always been the same guy he is a
brilliant engineer
and a masterful businessman who's
working on projects that he finds
meaningful
recently fanboys hyped him up to be some
anti-establishment tony stark humanity
saver that is flawless
but that's not who elon musk ever was
and one of his recent tweets has
crumbled this fake persona
this has left many fanboys feeling
betrayed by a character that elon musk
never was and that's really quite a
shame
personally though i'm glad that this
went down as it introduces balance and
healthy skepticism to what was
originally
irrational exuberance let's not let this
go too far though
as though elon musk is not a savior he
is a leading visionary
and nothing can change that do you guys
think the recent downturn in neon
support is healthy
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys thought this video explained
the controversy well
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and to consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one